because everything's programs and with
my laptop's program a canvas program
bonus program we are programmed as human
beings to only find peace in the room so
Allah our hearts yearn for the
remembrance of Allah what happens is
when we start to get that emptiness and
trying to fill it up with a girlfriend
or a boyfriend what happened is we make
that person or that that person our
happiness and once we do that and that
person lets us down and goals or cheats
on us or betrays us with those whatever
and goes our happiness leaves with them
when we put our happiness into a car and
something and we are will not be bored
of that car happiness fades away
wait our disciples away from that car we
look for a happiness into material
things and houses and what if it maybe
and we get bored why because the heart
is yearning for Allah you are given it
the wrong food you are given a
materialist English rejecting it cause
it doesn't want it partner whatever need
doesn't want it whatever you do it
doesn't want it rather than the one that
Apple it doesn't want it what does it
want
what Allah appears like I'm telling you
hearts would only find peace in the
remembrance of your note well mine this
is this is a law a law set out by Allah
just as there is a law mine is looking
these keys it's going to drop this is a
physical law that Allah has put in place
it's a physical earth Allah swim plane
just the same way same way there is a
medicine to below but you cannot similar
eyes is that our hands only find things
in the reservoir a ceremony I went to a
very casual branches and they ascend
before us our own planes also pilot
Allah the most merciful the most drugs
or praise you glory and gratitude belong
to him now I've got no substitutes okay
break from YouTube is reasonably today
done another videos are explained why he
left YouTube and I feel you know what I
think the video based on it and
but that was the video thing about react
to it and derive some lessons from it
which may be for the resolution can
benefit from as well as well as all of
us and you can send the video to my the
endosomal if you find it beneficial so
that is straight into it epic repetition
luck I recently texted a friend and I
said yo I'm high again right now but I'm
scared because I'm realizing that I'm
smoking again and I'm drinking again and
this time I feel that I'm doing it
because it's out of depression and out
of a low point in my life that I'm in so
the action that I'm doing every day and
the feelings that I'm feeling our
feelings of depression to the dimensions
and he's right
people usually click alcohol drugs etc
based on just wanting to live life to
the for this what they train like you
the sorcerer understanding of believing
that this is what life is about
carbon partying Xena whatever it may be
so that's one part music people take the
other part is when you go through
depression right now you're going
through madness whatever it may be so
you start of life by partying drinking
alcohol do whatever you want
etc then what happens is that routine
once you do that you realize that this
is not happiness this is not being a
happiness a pseudonymous feels intimate
inside me what happens if you start to
be kind of going to depression and when
you go into depression now to not win
get help on doing drugs and committing
zina because it's fun you're doing it
because now you're in a state of
depression and that's the norm that you
know and that's the only thing that you
know that you can turn to so I think
this was talking about which is true and
I said to be honest I never knew I was
in it until I was out of it this time
I'm able to recognize that I'm in it and
it showed me that you usually don't
recognize how low of a point you're at
until you get out of the situation
because then you're able to look back
and be like damn I was there and now I'm
here and you're able to appreciate the
current position that you are in life a
couple of months ago I quit like it's
not like oh I thought I
quit or oh I was confused or always
going through this and that not like I'm
gonna be 100% honest to you guys I can't
keep letting myself down I can't keep
letting them down
I can't keep letting the people around
me down and I 100% wholeheartedly
decided to quit I you know called my mom
and dad and I told them hey I don't you
to be scared for me I don't know what my
life has in store for me right now at in
terms of what I'm doing in my life I
don't know anymore but at that point in
time I just I wasn't there emotionally
spiritually mentally nothing of me was
here anymore I had lost my why you know
we all have why as to why we do what we
do
and the why should be your driving force
to anything you do in your life it
should be why you wake up in the morning
why you grind every day
why you make sacrifices you're why is
you know your reason your purpose and I
no longer had a purpose and I no longer
had a reason to justify why I do what I
do and why I put myself into the
situations that I put myself in okay he
seeing that he lost his wife why am I
doing this now obviously I don't know
that reason why she would do certain
things whatever it may be but in life
generally when we do things we are
believe me not to question why but it's
really crucial is really clearly why am
i doing what I'm doing and this a
question I don't know that ask why am I
doing this why I'm going to reduce your
videos what is it for why do I behave
like this why do I do this so a lot of
the times when we don't find that why
the purpose we get lost you know because
now and the message of the rise of this
is the fitler that innate disposition to
find happiness only in the remembrance
of Allah this is the wine that you
should live for why am i little do it
for the sake of Allah everything it
should be for the sake of allah subhanaw
taala as much as possible our Y should
be connected to the one that we worship
and when we don't have that Y and we
don't know that why and we don't have
that connection with that well which is
compromise also patent Allah then we go
into this hole and we are lost why am i
doing it okay fans make them happy this
that okay by making them unhappy so what
are they I'll do it for this reason
so whenever you do something other than
for the sake of Allah then you can't
really find true hundred because you
might be doing it for the people to make
them happy for your family especially
whatever it may be or it is good to make
this for your families or for saying a
lot but not finding that why is it big
hold a lot of people so according to and
not only know it not knowing your
purpose is another dilemma because not
knowing why am I here where am I going
please put me up what this all about
this wise is then answered and if you
don't understand okay a lot for me yup
Allah wants me to do this the reason
because of that and this is Jannah is my
goal why reason why cost so then you're
clear but we need to add that your loss
there's no right so you're just
basically like you just imagine either
codon is just looking for a way around
to get it it's a bit like that I think
maybe I'm not legal um just everything
around me started to not make sense and
I realized that you know as I went on I
mean guys I took four months off this
year and you would think that like I had
this mental breakthrough and I had this
like you know realization as to what I
want to do but I'm sitting here telling
you guys this has been a really really
really really really really really bad
year and I'm not talking about in the
sense of you know family problems and
this and that I'm talking about in the
sense of waking up every single day
going through the same actions doing the
same thing expecting different results
but getting nothing waiting for answers
praying for answers and nothing coming
your way and just not knowing what
you're supposed to do in life waking up
every morning just like brah what am I
supposed to be doing right now when I
watch this when I was woefully it makes
me think like this soul the sort of you
so deprived that it's on a brink of
like breaking like like I feel like the
brother is he sees it just seemed that
he's so disturbing the separation when I
wake up I'm like what am I supposed to
do and it's it it just makes it seem
like amazingly versatile and span
without cases if you forget my
remembrance you'll have a depressed life
now in no shape or form are saying that
foodie has completed with remember
summer I don't know I don't know yet
however it's important to have that
connection because if we don't have that
connection then we latitude you before
with us and this is really important but
insisted we don't forget to eat if we
know it was properly we are weak we
can't do nothing why do we look after
our sold we'll look after our body the
way wouldn't help ourself
you know absolute my main causes of
makeup what I'm going to tell it with my
my outer appearance and we must be my
body hundreds present somebody's not
complaining etc what about the soul what
about the soul when we deny the soul
what can happen you deprive the ground
I'd like to employ my the soul
breakdown so this is really important as
well I I didn't know what that was I
don't I didn't know what my reason was
when my purpose was I just felt empty so
everyday if you guys have been wondering
where I've been what have I been doing
when I was even up - I've been doing
nothing I've been doing nothing but
spending time with myself you know
trying to figure things out but that's
why I'm in the position now recognizing
that the thing that I was missing all
along and the thing that you know was
you know I was yearning for more than
anything was love inside myself identity
within myself
recognizing Who I am as a person and
knowing who I am as a person and knowing
that I'm worthy and valuable and like
love myself to that extent to be able to
love others around me and understand
that anything that comes into my life
I'm grateful for and you know I hold
gratitude towards and it's not something
that I need or something I need excess
of to fulfill my you know
no pit of endless you know
dissatisfaction and unhappiness around
me when I took my break I was waiting
for that breakthrough of Oh rejuvenation
come back strong come back happy you
know you got to motivate people you can
be called this you can be called that
but I come to you broken and I come to
you more afraid than I have ever been in
my entire life and I come to you with
more self-doubt than I've ever had a
mind to our life and I come to you with
more questions about my life in my
future than I've ever had in my entire
life I come to you with anxiety I come
to you with you know uncertainty I come
to you with whatever fears you might
think mingle through your head when you
put your head down to sleep at night
when you're going to sleep and you can't
get those thoughts out I come to you in
that form and letting me know that I'm
going through that and I'm going through
that heavily right now I can't promise
you you know the best version of me
right now I can't promise you the the
version of me that you once knew or that
you fell in love with like you might not
even recognize me as a person anymore
you might not like me as a person
anymore you thought that he's just
defined to the people that look you know
I'm going to be myself I can't be how do
you think I am always I usually am
etcetera this is really key I think he
takes it and I understand the YouTuber
like negative hate come and get you a
bit more than positive comments first go
okay hey quit bitching he's basically
more concerned about what people think
of him and he shouldn't he shouldn't
care she don't give a damn about what
anyone thinks about him as long as he's
true to himself and he to the one who
created it he shouldn't carry things
what you know and only to get that new
value as you can see I made his world
through some tests and trials etc they
didn't have that connection one well
maybe I don't know I don't know that
might be the cause but he shouldn't care
there's another problem that we will
feel is that we try to treat all the
people all the people that wouldn't go
in your grave and if I were going to
introduce myself in my most authentic
form it would be me here looking at you
right now
being able to tell you I'm going through
so damn much and that's why I'm here and
that's why I need you more than ever
right now when I used to use YouTube
before my happy place became the
scariest place that I've ever known
because of everything I allowed enter it
I used to be vulnerable and I used to
talk to you guys about what I'm going
through
see what he says this is where I need
you that cure the jaw is not soothing
needing his viewers
he needs his Lord at this time he really
really really needs to like take that
time out I literally like I think for
this hype anything except like truly to
say no one look I was what I have given
you the cure just try that for people if
you're watching this please just take a
break and fire up a lot of prescribed
try that
well my a lot committed to a lot of
promises promise is true try it
build your connection via road though
now go to Mecca go to the camera
stay there 2 weeks 3 week 4 week
whatever stay that build that Commission
with your Lord as we try that Rama
please please please try this please
that wasn't 0 series please editable to
me
this is the key you don't need then you
those followers you need your Lord and I
used to talk about depression opaline I
used to talk about when my bays weren't
going good and I used to talk about you
know my stresses and I used to talk
about everything but soon enough it
became but that wasn't the cool thing to
do and I got you know chastised for it
and criticized for it hated on for it so
I had to you know good mom and every
morning and I had to force myself to be
happy and I had to do all he had to put
on a stone even though he was going
through madness life so people were
judging for this and that whatever it
may be you know and he had to put an act
on why for the people the people would
never be too happy if you tries to find
you
within people or materialistic things
they would always always always that he
done what might always be later when you
do something it's a loan we do sell to
do so let's take a long one
I do good to you cannot because I all
good back I did for the sake of Allah
because you know what I know you will
let me down somewhere another so I am
doing this for the sake of Allah not
because I want something bad for me so
doing things when the people is never
gonna bring me happiness never because
they always gonna dig it up the one that
would never let you down is the one who
created you I need this more than ever
right now because I need an outlet to
talk about whatever it may be going
through my head and I need to stop
harnessing these emotions in these
bottles because I am living in fear
every single day every single day that I
chose to not pick up this cameras
because I'm terrified I'm terrified
about what the world has to say about me
I'm terrified about how people perceive
me I'm terrified of people's opinions
I'm terrified about reading anything
about myself the only thing that matters
is your Commission to avoid what you can
do to please him it doesn't care what
people think what you think don't matter
to you or like that's true freedom
because right now assume that both of
you in these shackles or tried to please
all the people that's sad that's sad
because that's not freedom you are
invisible shackles trying to please
other people Bravo and this is why maybe
the depression is happening and like I
said I can't promise you guys content
that's going to entertain you I can't
promise you guys content that's going to
grab your attention and I can't promise
you guys that I'm going to be able to
even be here every day because I do not
know I don't know how many conversations
I had with my mom or she would say when
are you posting again I want to be like
I'm trying mama and then one week would
turn to two with two three three would
turn to four and I still can't find the
strength or the courage to be able to
pick up the camera and just talk you
know I guess that's that man
I love you guys I appreciate you guys
and thank you for listening
I pray that I have the strength to pick
up the camera tomorrow and just talk to
it no matter if it be good bad positive
negative or anything I just hope that I
have the strength to be able to press
record and upload and try to help myself
and you right there who might be going
through something on your own until next
time I understand about to help people
exceptional but you see all centered on
save yourself and just how many members
from the Hellfire first and a lot of
people do this you know you're too busy
trying to help other people know if
you're loud and you need to help
yourself first you try to help other
people you do both on the drum help
yourself I just hope Allah for the truth
inshallah nomination event easy is what
amazing tandoori masala I just like I
said before bubblews if you're watching
this go to my car Bava go to matcom
you've tried everything
brother please try this ty the way of
your world once and he please
hi this then kind of eating me didn't
work try and then see to it didn't work
so guys hope you enjoyed it only
benefited shared into a broth of the
treatment genre please inshallah if you
watching this benefit from it are we
have these are more than happy and so I
hope you guys have benefit a lot from
this t-shirt in the friends and family I
thought I wanted a better careful till
next time goodbye
I know shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey
give me one I'm funny
subscribe